welcome to a special episode of chalk
radio
a podcast about inspired teaching at mit
from mit
open courseware i'm your host sarah
hansen
in this episode we want to share some
insight into the many ways we can
transition our traditional learning
environments
into remote ones we connected with
someone whose work
even before the pandemic hit has been
deeply focused on how learning is
changing our conversation started off
with what's become a familiar sound for
listeners with young ones at home
just so you know you might hear some
more of this in the background
throughout the episode
we're all doing the best we can working
from home right
hey girls anyhow
let's jump right in i'm justin reich so
i'm an
assistant professor in comparative media
studies and i run a lab called the
teaching systems lab
and the mission of the teaching systems
lab is to design
implement and research the future of
teacher learning and we try to figure
out new ways for teachers to learn
in online and blended ways in his work
justin partners with teachers and
instructors
curriculum designers software developers
researchers and experts from across
disciplines to help teachers adapt to
the changing world of learning
since the pandemic has shifted almost
all teaching to remote instruction
justin's work has adapted to the new
needs of instructors
i would say the bulk of my teaching
energy has gone into helping
k-12 educators and education policy
makers across the country
but most of my work has been trying to
provide some guidance
for schools and school leaders figuring
out what distance learning can look like
so for schools and teachers with little
or even no experience with online
instruction
where do they even begin to approach
remote learning
with so much changing each day what are
the most important things
educators should be thinking about these
are enormously
complicated issues to deal with you know
while you're trying to
feed millions more meals to kids than
you ever have before in large districts
or
big urban school systems while you're
trying to help your entire faculty
transition
almost instantaneously into a new model
of learning i mean doing all of these
things at the same time is just
immensely complicated
so i would encourage people to keep it
simple
that's one principle a second principle
is to really think about how you can
partner with students and
in k-12 with their families so the
coronavirus feels like it's something
being done
to us it feels like something that we
have very little control over
but our response to the coronavirus can
be something that we build together
so i would encourage education leaders
at every level
from you know college provosts to
elementary school teachers to school
principals superintendents whatever it
is
asking and partnering with everybody in
the system is a really important part of
responding
to remote learning what most emergency
remote learning should look like is kind
of a package of asynchronous materials
that's coupled with lots of frequent
check-ins
synchronous versus asynchronous teaching
or offering learning experiences at a
specific time
versus providing students who have the
material to engage with on their own
time
is at the core of justin's message for
teachers
so in lots of circumstances synchronous
learning is not going to work for people
it's hard for all of us to line up our
schedules in k-12 circumstances
you know you've got a teacher who's got
a first grader a fourth grader and a
seventh grader
who's trying to teach her kids who are
ninth graders but they have siblings who
are third graders and fourth graders and
twelfth graders
and trying to line up all those
schedules so that people can be
synchronously
in front of the one computer that exists
in a household or to use the amount of
bandwidth because your home only
you know allows one synchronous video
call to happen at a time it's just too
complicated
so for the most part what educators
should be thinking of setting up
is some kind of package of curriculum
that lasts about a week or two
maybe with some sort of daily guides of
what people might be doing each day
recognizing that people might have to do
two days of work in one day because they
get busy with other stuff for another
day or things like that
and then providing frequent points of
check-in so a huge part of what
motivates us as learners
is when we're getting feedback on what
we're doing and this doesn't have to be
based around grades or numbers or other
things like that just that was a great
idea keep that up tell me more about
that
wow it looks like you did more on this
assignment than anyone you've done
before
what else could you do with this how
could you take this further it seems
like you're interested in this
shifting so heavily toward asynchronous
teaching
might feel strange at first but this one
change may address
in a small way some of the equity issues
school systems
and individuals are facing right now
such as differing access to dependable
wi-fi
there's no survey that was done in
advance of the pandemic
that asked questions like do you
have one device for each school age
child or learner in your home and a
broadband connection
and a printer to be able to print things
out like we actually don't know
how well families are equipped for this
pandemic but it's pretty clear
that a lot of our low-income housing is
in broadband deserts or
isn't networked in i mean there's lots
of people in urban environments who in
their typical daily lives
can get by you know with having one
mobile broadband device in their house
and that's plenty
but now if you've got three school-aged
kids at home your
demands have just increased
substantially but i think partnering
with students i think really thinking
about
who are the most vulnerable learners in
our community
there are some people who come from
affluent well-equipped homes and they're
able to weather this crisis in a very
different way than if you're going back
into a poverty impacted place that is
really feeling the effects of the
recession
and the coronavirus i think the students
that aren't reaching out i think the
ones that that are not doing well
i think we have a special i think we
always have this responsibility but i
think during a
pandemic we have a special
responsibility to reach out to those
students and say
how can i help you with this how can i
keep you on track
and helping students stay on track is
another big part of the puzzle for a lot
of educators out there
especially for classes that form the
foundations for later learning
i mean i think the other thing that
universities and other places need to do
is be strategic
about what it is that we want students
to be able to learn
so if you were to go across the ocw
catalog i think you would find
at least two types of courses one type
of course
is where to study a discipline you
sample from a canon
so literature is the most obvious
example of this
but i think it appears in stem classes
and other places as well
if you were to take a shakespeare class
at mit you wouldn't read all of
shakespeare's work
you would read some selected sample of
that work and we would probably be
willing to say you know we read
uh romeo and juliet and twelfth night
and a couple sonnets before we left
and we were gonna do that much work
again in the fourth quarter but actually
this time we're just gonna read henry v
and we'll do it a little bit more slowly
and that'll be fine you know that is
that is a less of a sampling of the
canon that we would have done previously
but it's a perfectly reasonable sampling
of the canon will give you your
emergency pass grade
everything is fine there are other
courses in which there's a sequential
building of material
of understanding in which subsequent
courses depend upon that sampling of
understanding
so our introduction to statistics class
it's not
suitable to say to a student that we're
just going to do you know
half of multiple regression and we're
just not going to teach you the other
half or figure it out on their own
i mean one of the things that i think at
the department level or at other levels
people need to do is to say
there are some courses that we
strategically reduced and those young
people will be fine for the rest of
their lives and we don't have to worry
about it
there are other courses that we had to
strategically reduce in a pandemic but
we've got to figure out
how we support students in learning that
material
so they don't show up at intermediate
statistics in the fall
without the preparation that they need
to be successful and still the sort of
lingering effects of the pandemic so
that's a kind of strategic question
it's probably best resolved at the
department level
you know something along the lines of
who are the students in our core classes
that we think missed learning materials
that they really are gonna need
and how are we gonna supplement over the
summer or right when people come back in
august or in the fall
or whatever the new model looks like to
identify the areas in which
it's not okay to just uh strategically
reduce but instead we got to figure out
how we help people
get the learning that they need to be
successful in subsequent courses
when i asked justin about putting new
teaching approaches into practice
and developing materials to support
educators during covet 19
we got to talking about education at
scale
from the system as a whole to each
individual participant
there's such a wide range of needs and
no
one prescription for addressing them all
and in a time when teachers should be
focusing on partnering with students and
families
and identifying how to strategically
reduce and recover
content area material open educational
resources
may have an important role to play
students differ so much from place to
place
you know one of the things that i'm
seeing is that a lot of big districts
are
creating sort of sample lessons sample
schedules
those kinds of things but my initial
evidence is that a lot of teachers
aren't using them
not necessarily because they're bad or
wrong but just because they
like aren't right for where their kids
are right now
and so you know a lot of teachers feel
the need to be basically kind of
invent you know inventing their own new
distance learning curriculum
as they're learning a whole series of
new practices and co-inventing them with
their students
and you know finding the 40 of their
kids
who aren't answering emails or
responding to phone calls
and you know facilitating their own kids
instruction at home i mean i think
that's something that
people really need to keep in mind but i
would say that if schools are facing
waves of closure in the fall or other
kinds of challenges like this i would
really encourage people to say
even though it's not exactly the way i
would want to teach it
there may be a better comparative
advantage for faculty members to focus
on that check-in that facilitation role
rather than trying to sort of generate
original content
by video you know without a studio
and without all the other resources that
we need or consider you know
doing less of that consider saying oh i
like you know in my solid state
chemistry course i can find
these mit open courseware videos and six
of the ten lectures
are great um and i'm gonna only record
four for the period that we have to miss
in the fall or other kinds of things
like that um you know i mean i think one
of the things that we've discovered
is that faculty find it very difficult
to
identify whole online courses
that they like to just take and sort of
use as textbooks
but it strikes me that a pandemic is
exactly the sort of time
in which people might want to employ
that kind of thinking
one of the most important factors in
determining our best way forward
is looking at how we actually measure
the success of remote learning
who do we look to for guidance and
models of what is best right now
it's not as simple as it might seem so
we just did this report
about the remote learning guidance
offered by all 50 states
and one of the cautions that we have in
the report is there are good reasons to
believe
that lots of teachers are not doing what
this says that
educational systems are what we call
loosely coupled so there are tightly
coupled systems in our society like the
military
if a general in the military says
everyone's hair should be shorter than x
inches
then you know within weeks there will be
you know hundreds of thousands of
soldiers around the world whose hair is
shorter than
those number of inches teaching is not
like that education policy policymakers
leaders
all the time make edicts and teachers
shift through them
and they apply them as they see fit in
their own context for a variety of
reasons
and because of the incredible
granularity of teaching in a lot of
cases
we just don't know what's happening at
the classroom level
i think most of the places that we say
are
doing a good job of remote learning
their
primary characteristic is that they are
affluent
one way you can do a good job of remote
learning is have a bunch of kids
in stable homes with broadband internet
connections
who each have their own device and if
those conditions exist
then you will have a thing that looks a
lot like good learning if those
conditions don't exist
regardless of the heroic effort of
teachers you will have things that look
like
less effective learning the way that my
colleague
trustee mcmillan cotton said this is
like the number one thing that education
has
to reduce inequality is the school the
school is the thing that we've lost
and there's not a mechanism to like
rapidly make up
uh those sort of equalizing forces so so
that's a long way of
saying that i don't think i know of
places that i would say
wow these folks are doing a really great
job addressing this
i think one measure that people are
using to define a good job
is who can do things most quickly who
can get
the thing that looks closest to what
school looked like before
up and running the fastest i'm not
convinced at the end of this
that that will end up being a good proxy
for better
and in the end it seems like better
learning while we are at home
simply looks different than what we're
used to and the more we can embrace that
the better off we as parents students
and educators may be
i've encouraged both families and
educators
to if possible not put too much stock in
trying to recreate school at home
there are lots of things that schools
can do in their local environments that
are going to be really hard to replicate
in a home environment but there's lots
of learning
that can happen at home and what we need
to do is as best we can cultivate and
celebrate that learning i was
interviewed recently by a reporter from
the arctic sounder
which is the newspaper of the north
slope of alaska
very bad connectivity up there and so
remote learning is not going to look
like what it looks like in an affluent
boston suburb and what a lot of teachers
there were saying is like look this is a
great time
for families to strengthen their
connection to traditional anupiak values
this is a great time for kids to learn
how to cook and bake
and sew and bead and repair snow
machines
and do all the kinds of learning that
can happen really well at home
so i think you know to families out
there that are sort of struggling
during this period it is totally normal
to struggle
during a pandemic if you if you feel
like this is hard and is anxiety
provoking
that is normal and lots of people feel
that way and i think our goals
we can't put too much pressure on
ourselves about keeping up and staying
up and things like that
think about what can you do to maximize
the learning and the resilience that
happens
right now and if part of what we do to
do that is like teach our kids new
chores
you know if it's if it's time for those
nine and ten year olds to start doing
their first load of laundry or their six
or seven year olds to do their first
sink of dishes
like that's great learning too that we
can do really well at the home
and we could probably do some reading
and some math and and some social
studies and science along the way too
you know and some some of that relates
to the first piece of advice that i
offered before
which is let's partner with our learners
and if those letters happen to be our
own kids
you know so much the better to be
partnering with them
[Music]
if you're interested in learning more
about teaching remotely during the covet
19 pandemic
check out justin's wbur on point
interview
where he talks about how colleges and
universities are teaching
students virtually we've provided a link
to that in our show notes
justin also hosts teach lab a new
podcast that explores the art
and craft of teaching several of the
show's recent episodes focus on teaching
during covid19 that link can be found in
the show notes as well
if open educational resources are
important in your practice of teaching
or learning
particularly now during covet 19 please
consider supporting the work of mit open
courseware
there are lots of ways to do this one is
simply by listening to this podcast
and sharing it with a friend you can
also share the ocw
website with your colleagues and we
really love
hearing about how you use ocw materials
because we use your stories to inspire
others to make use of who we are
or if you'd like to help fund our work
please visit our website to make a gift
however you can support us we thank you
until next time please stay safe i'm
sarah hansen
from mit open courseware